[Musique]
le crâne dedans non je pense qu'il a disparu
car en comptant qu'il manque à l'école
ça fait un mètre 20. la
taille de cinq mètres
donc la taille de ça qui craint
ce sera le quatrième Mort que j'ai
vu  Je
n'ai jamais vu de bouton live
[Musique]
J'ai voyagé en Basse-Californie au Mexique
où je suis monté à bord du Seahorse. C'est un
navire géré par Sea Shepherd, une organisation à but non lucratif
défendant toute la faune marine contre la
pêche non réglementée et illégale.
Nous étions 19 à bord, tout le monde est à
bord.  ils ont entre 20 et 30 ans et viennent du
monde entier, ils donnent de leur
temps pendant des semaines, parfois des mois à la
fois et je voulais passer quelques jours
ici pour comprendre leur engagement
ainsi que l'importance de cette mission,
c'est formidable d'avoir vos gars à bord
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne travaillent pas sur les navires,
soyez normalement vigilants à tout moment,
donc si vous êtes de garde, soyez éveillé, soyez
vigilant, comme si quelque chose ne va pas, on
compte sur vous pour le signaler à
quelqu'un d'autre et il y a beaucoup d'équipage
ce n'est pas de service qui dort donc
quand vous êtes sur DDP Vigilant, nous sommes dans une
zone qui pourrait être potentiellement dangereuse
et nous sommes sur le navire, d'accord, alors
évidemment pas d'alcool, pas de drogue, pas de tabac,
nous allons partir et commencer à
surveiller le zti  La Zeta est une
zone de tolérance zéro, c'est-à-dire la zone dans
laquelle personne n'est autorisé à pêcher ou à faire
l'une de ces activités, et notre
rôle ici est de nous assurer que personne ne
met de filets dans l'eau, ce sera donc
notre priorité.  objectif pour les prochains
jours ou dans un avenir prévisible
[Musique]
J'ai découvert Sea Shepherd alors que j'étais à
l'université pour étudier la biologie, deux mois plus
tard, j'étais déjà là,
donc ici nous avons le aperçu du refuge Makita. Les
études sur la population de vaquita
sont réalisées grâce à l'acoustique.  donc les
scientifiques ont posé des hydrophones et
ensuite ils analysent les données parce qu'ils
sont vraiment difficiles à voir sur la
surface, ils doivent être très plats, ce
sont des animaux vraiment timides qui s'éloignent
des bateaux et du bruit, pouvez-vous
me montrer  à quoi ça ressemble, le son,
avons-nous accès à cela Oui en fait
[Musique] on
dirait que je ne m'attendais pas à
cette haute fréquence,
donc tout le cours de bakida qui a eu lieu a consisté à
récupérer toutes les autopsies,
ils étaient en bonne santé, ils n'en avaient pas
adcs, ils avaient de la nourriture sur l'estomac,
donc leur déclin est uniquement
à cause des engins de pêche, des choses sûres
qu'un squelette de forme violette d'un
but
est comme ça
[La musique]
est un petit but qui est endémique à
cette partie du golfe de Californie et
il est tellement en danger qu'il
pourrait en rester seulement six,
mais personne ne pêche intentionnellement le vaquita,
leurs pêcheurs accessoires
grandissent après que le poisson tutuappa ait à peu
près la même taille que sa vessie natatoire est
très apprécié dans la médecine traditionnelle chinoise
qui a créé un noir
marché lié au crime organisé avec des
conséquences mortelles pour tous les
animaux marins qui vivent ici à
un mètre virgule sept,
ils l'appellent la cocaïne de la mer,
donc même les gens qui n'étaient pas des pêcheurs sautaient
à Bangas avec la
mer netsu pour essayer d'attraper Toto albas  parce que
la valeur de leur frère jumeau était
plus élevée que l'or si le boucher avait cette
Chloé il serait très content ça va
être très contrarié parce qu'il a perdu le filet
et la vessie natatoire de ça donc il a perdu
des milliers de dollars
étrangers
dont tout ça  c'est illégal ce
qu'ils font, oui,
remarquez l'arrêt arrière à l'intérieur de cette ETA
et oui, parce que lors de l'inspection, nous avons vu
qu'ils mettaient nos filets de pêche,
alors ce type a dit qu'il y avait du jaune puis du
bleu, ce type bougeait donc nous avons ensuite
informé la Marine  de l'activité qui
se passe à l'intérieur et ils sont maintenant
sur
plusieurs navires, donc nous donnons une
distance proche aux activités afin que nous
puissions continuer à surveiller ce qui se passe.
Je vois les différentes approches réduites pour
les trouver
[Musique]
et bien, il y a trois consciences,
je pense qu'ils  aussi parfois, prenons leur
chance, voyons tout ce qu'ils peuvent donner
ou combien de temps cela va prendre avant de l'
obtenir,
merci,
est-ce que ça part, on
dirait que c'est vrai ouais
[Musique]
oh nous allons voir comment cela secoue
les Defenders également sur  à sa façon,
le défenseur est un navire naval plus petit,
plus agile et capable de se déplacer plus
librement
[Applaudissements]
Je suppose que Banger est vraiment personnel
oh ouais, ils ont définitivement des filets dans leurs
mains oui
ouais,
je veux dire, on dirait que leur bateau est plein
de filets
[Musique]
ce qu'ils font, c'est qu'ils travaillent sur un
système à deux frappes, ce qui signifie que la première
frappe est comme un avertissement et retire
les chevilles des doigts et des
personnes à bord, puis la deuxième
frappe consiste à prendre leurs filets et éventuellement à
faire face à des poursuites judiciaires.  donc cela semble
fonctionner parce que nous n'avons pas beaucoup de
pêche ce jour-là, il n'y a pas de
banquiers,
nous fournissons un regard international sur cette
situation et nous informons du rôle de ce qui
se passe exactement dans le
refuge vaquita et de ce que nous voyons chaque jour.  que
nous sommes ici, c'est
notre chef Maddie, ça sent vraiment
bon là-dedans, en fait, comme tous les membres de l'équipage
ici, ils disent qu'ils ne
mangeront que des végétaliens, il y a un chef à bord,
donc ils ont le luxe de faire
préparer tous leurs repas
ici, nous avons  les chefs
c'est Pablo il est notre
médecine médicale ce sont des
médecins notre service de nettoyage médical ouais
service de nettoyage
tout nous sommes tous un peu de
tout ici n'importe quel savon, comme
tout ce que nous utilisons va être
biodégradable  y compris tout le
détergent,
donc environ un jour sur deux, quelqu'un fait
toute la lessive et cela
alterne entre les personnes, peu importe qui
vous êtes, vous avez une sorte de corvée sur
le bateau, puis il y a la cabine la nuit,
nous allumons ces feux rouges, donc c'est  tout
pour la lumière rouge est sensible pour vos yeux
ou bon pour vos yeux, cela vous empêche d'
avoir une vision nocturne afin que vous puissiez sortir
et vous pouvez toujours voir si vous devez
sortir sur le pont ou quelque chose comme ça, bien sûr,
c'est l'autre cabine  nous allons juste nous
assurer que personne n'est
donc en sécurité, personne n'est ici mais
oh Richie, que diriez-vous du bruit et de
l'intimité et comme il y a beaucoup de bruit,
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'intimité
[Musique]
le temps vient de
s'améliorer
[Musique]
beaucoup
dernièrement  la nuit a été un peu difficile vers
trois heures du matin nous avons eu un
temps vraiment mauvais j'ai eu vraiment le mal de mer et j'ai
été surpris de constater qu'en fait
beaucoup de personnes dans l'équipage ont aussi eu le
mal de mer
médecin le cuisinier il n'y a pas de déjeuner préparé
ce matin
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
étrangère
opère dans ces eaux depuis
2015. ils appellent cette opération Milagro
qui signifie miracle en espagnol au fil des
années ils prétendaient avoir récupéré 1
000 filets de ces eaux et voilà,
100 nuits faites mais leur simple  la présence
ici a créé beaucoup de controverses, c'est
déjà une campagne étrangère à haut risque simplement en raison de
l'agression que nous rencontrons chaque
jour avec le braconnage ici, donc nous
devons faire face à cela en termes de risques
mais la réalité du climat d'entraînement
en ce moment, ici dans le haut Golfe, cela a
beaucoup changé, les entraîneurs sont en
plein jour, ils pêchent sans
masque, ils utilisent des bouées pour marquer l'
ensemble de leurs filets, c'est quelque chose que
je n'ai personnellement pas vu dans tous mes
Milagros, ils  Nous sommes plus agressifs que
jamais,
nous avons des attaques de plus en plus fréquentes
et de moins en plus de bangers et de
braconniers viennent se joindre à ces attaques.
[Musique] merci,
je ne sais pas. D'
accord, des petits garçons de la Marine viennent
ici,
alors  Les bouchers continuent de lancer
mais le mal est là maintenant aussi un petit
bloc de la part de l'équipe de l'armée, nos défenses ont
très bien tenu, nous avons pu
sécuriser le navire, nous avons eu des
dommages au navire à cause de nombreuses pierres et de
deux molotovs qui ont été bien lancés
même si nous  sommes tous des citoyens du
monde, il y a toujours des inquiétudes lorsque vous
êtes
un navire international opérant dans
un autre pays, nous savons quels sont les échanges commerciaux
et nous savons que cela pourrait devenir aérien.
Je n'ai pas peur d'être ici et
même s'il y en avait.  alors je le serais
toujours de toute façon, donc ce n'est pas vraiment
quelque chose que je prends en considération
pour ma propre sécurité, bien sûr, j'ai pris en
considération l'équipage et j'ai essayé d'
assurer leur sécurité, mais je sais aussi qu'ils
sont également là pour une raison pour laquelle
ils aussi  préparés à tout ce qui
pourrait arriver par rapport à ce que nous avons vu dans le
passé,
nous sommes donc définitivement redescendus pour des raisons de
sécurité. Concepts
déjeuner déjeuner déjeuner déjeuner
déjeuner
[Musique]
Je ne me sens pas très bien ce matin, le
travail le plus important
semble être trois heures  les gens, c'est
vrai, dans un cas comme celui-ci, nous devons commencer à les
approcher pour mieux les voir,
ouais, de plus près, voir si nous pouvons déterminer s'ils
ont des Nets et ce qu'ils font exactement
en ce moment, ils quittent le CDA mais ils l'
étaient  Je me suis arrêté là pendant un moment donc je
leur écris toujours que c'est une
pêche illégale potentielle, leur comportement était
suspect,
ceux-là où ce champignon était à l'intérieur
du CTA donc c'était illégal
donc ce filet a une grosse taille de désordre qui
coupe ses plies
et nous avons vu comme  Eh bien, dans les animaux capturés
sur ces filets, comme ceux-ci, ces
panga et quelques autres que nous avons
pu filmer avec le drone, nous avons aussi vu des
requins, ainsi que des petits requins
sous ces petits poissons,
cela ressemble à une espèce de
raie différente et donc soit  poisson
merci ça
a été un voyage difficile et stimulant
je dirais que toutes ces années presque
là presque là ouais mais ce qui
me rend aussi triste et ça me rend triste c'est
que bien sûr les bakitas ne sont pas le seul
animal qui est mort dans le filet je
'  J'ai vu des lions de mer, des requins, des tortues,
nous avons trouvé des baleines et des célibataires dans ces
filets,
donc c'est toute la vie qu'il y a ici
qui est l'une des grandes surprises que j'ai
eu la première fois que je suis venu ici,
combien d'animaux différents, quelle est la richesse de cette
région.  Je suis triste parce qu'ils mouraient
ces jours-là.
Je pense que nous sommes des extrémistes, les gens
qualifient les écologistes de gens qui
prennent les choses hors de proportion et qui
exagèrent ce qui se passe et je
pense que c'est aussi la partie la plus dangereuse
de tout cela.  c'est que si vous
regardez vraiment ce qui se passe, nous n'exagérons pas,
nous avons du super équipement sur cette
partie que nous n'avions pas sur la précédente
sur les Cutters et je suis plus qu'heureux
de vous expliquer comment cela fonctionne et  ce que
nous pouvons en faire et c'est essentiellement
un écho émis sous stéroïdes et vous pouvez
obtenir une imagerie 3D de ce qui se passe
sous l'eau. Nous essayons de
voir ce qui se passe au fond de l'océan, de
voir exactement à quelle profondeur il se trouve et de voir si nous
pouvons trouver  tous les filets et les vieux
restes fantomatiques qui sont laissés pour que nous puissions
les supprimer et notre but est d'aimer
cette zone et de monter et descendre jusqu'à ce
qu'elle soit complètement violette au
cours de nombreuses années, ils ont pris
des centaines de minutes  et maintenant nous avons du
mal à le trouver. Je suis vraiment
excité de ne trouver aucun besoin. Je
cherche à le trouver et je fais vraiment de
mon mieux mais je n'en ai trouvé aucun, donc je suis
vraiment ravi de cet effet,
n'est-ce pas ?  maintenant, la population est encore
estimée entre 20 et six
colis
si les bakitas étaient laissés seuls si tous les
dangers étaient éliminés de leur mer
leur population pourrait retourner là où
elle était chaque année où ils font une enquête
ils voient ils voient des moteurs avec  les veaux,
ce qui signifie qu'ils respirent toujours,
ils sont toujours là, ils se battent toujours
[Musique]
l'un de mes principaux points à retenir est que notre
implication fait une différence si
vous ne suivez pas la solution, vous n'arrêtez pas de
manger du poisson  alors certainement une partie du
problème,
peut-être que vous avez l'impression que vos actions en tant
qu'individu ont commencé à avoir une plus grande
influence, mais c'est le cas, nous allons
changer le monde et nous pouvons changer le
destin non seulement d'une espèce mais aussi d'un
environnement et éventuellement de  le monde
merci